turkey has two presidential candidates
are attempting to win over vote as ahead
of Sunday's runoff both are appealing to
nationalists now third place candidates
is out of the race opposition candidate
has received the backing of the small
far-right victory party it supported
organ in the first round Let's cross
over to Russell in Ankara who's
following events for us now there's been
a great deal of support uh for the
various candidates so just tell us a
little bit more about the main
opposition leader who's trying to you
might say oust president erdogan
oh
well today the leader of the victory
part which is an internationalist party
in Turkey it was founded uh quite a
while ago so it's not one of the old
parties in Turkey so he and and the the
leader of the opposition uh came out
today they had a joint oppressor and so
constello has said you know for the uh
for the benefit of the company they had
to build an alliance but it was the um
who has spoken uh mostly so he said that
they have agreed on a document the first
uh the item in that document is that the
turkishness remains as the backbone of
the constitution in the company and the
second item that I have agreed on that
13 million refugees will be sent back to
their countries within a year however
the statistics in Turkey do not back
this this figure so according to
official figures in Turkey there are 3.8
million refugees but he has been
claiming that official figures do not
reflect the reality he says that there
are at least 13 million refugees living
in turkey and the other one was that
particularly in the Eastern provinces
where the the Kurdish the Kurds make up
the majority of the population if any of
the authority there is related to the
pkk a Kurdish armed group that is
outlawed in Turkey so they will be
sacked and instead of them the trustees
are going to be appointed so he said
that if he called on the Turkish public
and said that if you do not want your
country to turn into a refugee stand and
if you want your woman or daughter's
wives to be able to save the world on
the streets so come up and support us so
he's implying that the refugees are
harassing on on women and he's implying
that now the refugees are going to take
over demographically and so on so this
has been his main rhetoric since three
years that he has been focusing on the
threat of the refugees he believes that
refugees are posing attract the National
Security and now we meet us that the
leader of the far-right victory party
Ultra nationalist Victory party is now
in Alliance with the table of six which
is the the Coalition of the opposition
six opposition parties uh competing
against President Antoine so Russell
will these statements really impact on
the electorate are they listening
carefully and do they really care
Well for now it's quite difficult to
predict which kind of impact it will
have on the results however there will
be a couple of factors in play here
first as his party is quite near it's
not clear whether he will be able to
mobilize his Waters uh in favor of uh
Kamal the oppositions uh presidential
candidate because the Loyalty of his
voters has not been tested yet so that
question Still Remains if you will be
able to convince his supporters to vote
for Kamal cholesterol another issue here
is is that after this agreement what
would be the reaction of the Kurdish
Waters in The Kurdish majority cities uh
in in Eastern Turkey because so one of
the the Kurdish greenlaf party has been
supporting and now this
ultra-nationalist party being in the
same Alliance we do not know what's
going to be their reaction just
yesterday they have seen that one of the
MPS of the Kurdish party has said that
not going to the polls remains as an
ocean and many people in turkey has
received that as a threat because simply
the weekly party is promising that even
if they are elected they're going to be
sacked and instead of them the trustees
are going to be appointed one of the
other important thing is that so the
table of six the the opposition is an
alliance and many of the parties do not
like this kind of approach we have seen
that after the first round of the
election the nationalism is on Rise and
Mr Kamal the soft spoken Democrat
um has changed his narrative and they
have seen that he went went with the
more nationalistic tone and focusing
more and more on the the red the trash
that they're coming from the refugees so
many of the parties in his Alliance are
not happy with this nationalist tone and
now with Victory party being in the
alliance is not clear whether Mr
chemical is going to be able to keep the
unity of the alliance on or not however
many of these questions are going to be
answered what in the runoff on May 28th
Russell said thank you